in today's law vegas now eric palacios  from eric palacios and associates the  sponsors of this next segment explains  what are some of the penalties one gets  if receiving a dui take a look  i'm eric palacios welcome to the legal  minute this week's question is what are  the penalties for a dui there are six  main penalties first two days to six  months in jail  second 24 to 96 hours of community  service  third dui school fourth finds between  400 to 1 000  fifth you have to attend a victim impact  panel and finally sixth your license may  be suspended for 185 days in today's  world with uber and lyft there's no  reason to drive under the influence  we'll see you next week here on the  legal minute  and for more information give eric  palacios and associates a call at  702-444-7777  las vegas now will be